-Last time you were on our show,
the world
was a different place.
We went all over New York City,
Grand Central Terminal,
Katz's Deli.
We were on the subway.
Do you have a favorite part
of that day?
-Grand Central.
-Yeah.
-Subway.
-Yeah!
-Korean heart!
-I think my favorite
was in Grand Central when --
'Cause we had --
it was 3:00 in the morning.
There was no one there,
just you guys,
and I was standing back,
watching.
And the choreography
was so perfect.
And it sounded so great.
I mean, I've never seen
dancing like this.
You were jumping
over each other,
people jumping in,
and doing that.
I go, "Oh, my gosh."
And I remember I went up
to Jungkook -- this was back
when you could hug somebody.
And I went over,
I gave you a hug,
I go, "That was great, buddy,"
and I gave you a hug.
And I could feel --
I could feel your heart beating
through your back.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
-It was like,
"These guys are working hard."
It was so impressive.
And this was
3:00 in the morning,
4:00 in the morning in New York.
And I was like,
"These guys, man.
That's why
they're the biggest band.
They're putting the work in."
-Jimmy, actually,
we've never taken a train
or a subway in New York.
Never done it.
So we don't know --
we didn't know, like,
how important
or big the station was.
But you know, looking at you,
you were like --
you was telling me, "Do you know
how important this is?
Do you know how big this is?"
And looking at you, that time we
got, like, "Yo, this is big!
Jimmy's so nervous!"
-[ Laughing ]
-That was
the most impressive moment.
-I was so nervous, so excited.
-Yeah.
-You knocked it out of the park.
It was great.
One of the things
your fans love about BTS
is how much you give back.
When COVID-19 broke out,
you made a bunch of donations
to help people
affected by the virus.
You also donated
$1 million to concert crews,
the crew that
is out of work right now.
Is giving back something that
was always important to you?
-We just wanted to help
and do what we can
so that things can get better.
-You guys
gave a great graduation speech
as part of YouTube's
"Dear class of 2020" event.
Does it make you think about
your own high school experience?
What were you guys like
back then?
RM, do you want to start?
What were you like?
-I was like --
kind of like a nerd.
I was, like, all about studying.
And I just liked to listen to
rap music like Eminem and Nas,
but I was just, like, a --
just a good student.
-V, how about you?
-"V, wake up."
-[ Laughs ]
-Jimmy!
-Good boy, good boy.
Jimin, that's awesome.
Respect, respect.
-Jimin, good boy.
Me too, good boy.
-You bad boy.
-Bad boy.
-Jimin, what were you like
in high school?
-Jin, I didn't skip over you.
What were you like
in high school?
-[ Laughs ]
-You don't have to,
you don't have to have one.
Suga?
-Bad boy.
-Bad!
-No, no.
-That's not good.
-J-Hope.
-Bad boy.
-J-Hope, I think that
you were like --
probably, like,
a big performer in high school.
Am I -- Am I right?
-That's right.
-That's hilarious.
That's --
I could see that,
I could see that.
Jungkook, when you were
in high school,
the band was actually at your
high school graduation?
What would you say to any kid
out there who's watching
and dreams of being
the next BTS?
-That's good advice.
That's great advice.
-Yeah!
-Yeah, yeah!
[ Applause ]
-Applause, applause!
-Oh, my gosh.
What I really do love
about you guys,
from working with you
and seeing you work is,
you have great work ethic.
You really are professional,
but you're also very funny.
You have a sense --
a great sense of humor.
And please don't ever lose that.
-We gonna take your crown,
Jimmy!
-[ Laughing ]
We have another incredible
performance from you guys
later tonight in the show.
BTS will be performing
"Black Swan."
BTS, everybody!
Their new album, "BE,"
is available for preorder now
at the Weverse shop.
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."
Stick around, everybody!